okay so we divided up the brain one way
and now we're going to divide it up
another way and so this is the brain
from the top down and you know you have
two hemispheres and you might think well
why do you need two hemispheres do you
know by the way some of you probably
know this that Gazzaniga who's a
relatively famous neuropsychologist
studied split brain patients now you
know that your cortical hemispheres your
brain is united down in the subcortical
areas you know it's sort of stuck
together although you have twin you have
twins of many of the subcortical
structures like you have two hippocampi
two amygdala for example one on each
side but at the top the hemispheres are
quite separate but they're connected by
the corpus callosum which makes them
communicate it's kind of interesting
because you kind of wonder well why
aren't they just all glued together you
know and what it seems to indicate is
that there's some utility of functional
independence combined with some utility
of communication you know so it might be
like do you really want to be networked
at the same time to everyone in the
world it's like no you don't you want
some narrow channel pathways so that
only the important information comes
through so it sort of maybe like the
right hemisphere is one kind of
computational device in the left
hemisphere is another kind of
computational device of course they're
not computational devices but you get
the point and only the important
information the processed information
from the right hemisphere goes across
and only the processed information from
the left hemisphere goes across
something like that whatever if you have
someone who's epileptic or
or that has brain illness of some sort
of a specific type it's usually epilepsy
but not always and you do surgery on
them and you cut the corpus callosum
what you find weirdly enough is that
each hemisphere develops its own
personality and so it's kind of and this
is other evidence I would say for the
idea that what the brain does is produce
personalities right you can keep pairing
the brain down and what it's going to do
is produce lower and lower resolution
personalities all the way down to the
bottom they're just known as detailed
they're like a if you lost say 80% of
your cortex randomly you'd sort of be
like a thumbnail of your
so you'd still be you but just not at
the same detail so I'll tell you here's
an interesting idea from the Catholics
it kind of goes along with the Avatar
idea
so the Catholics had been wrestling for
a long time with with the question about
how God could have fit himself in a
human body because you could imagine
that would obsessed Christians like God
is great big God in a little bitty body
but God in there just bursts the
boundaries well they have this idea
called kenosis which means emptying and
so the idea is that God had the empty
himself out before it get inhabit a
human body and it's very much like a
thumbnail idea so you know and young
would have of course thought exactly
that the self was a thumbnail of God I
mean if he wouldn't put it that way but
definitely that's that's where his
thinking was leading so so that's a
pretty damn cool idea so anyways so this
is from I I develop this before I read
what I'm going to tell you but it
doesn't matter because I'm going to talk
about it from another theorists point of
view the guy I'm going to tell you about
his name is al conan goldberg and he's a
neuropsychologist and he was one of
luring his students who ended up in new
york and goldberg was obviously
influenced by Luria and all the Sokolov
and vinegared older and gray and all
those people that i've already talked to
you about and he was interested in why
you have two hemispheres well there's a
bunch of things that you can say broadly
speaking about the hemispheres and I've
written them some of them down there so
the right hemisphere this is an
idealized representation of a relatively
highly lateralized
right-handed male and the reason I'm
saying that is men seemed to be more
lateralized than women and the
right-handed lateralization is the
standard kind but you know the brain can
be lateralized to all sorts of ways you
what you might say is that there's a
bunch of ways of looking at it one way
you can look at it is that your cortex
gets colonized by underlying structures
so and that each underlying structure is
likely to colonize a particular area so
for example when you when you are born
and you wake up and you see your eyes
are going to
colonize your visual cortex most likely
because it's sort of adapted for that
but if you don't have a visual cortex
then your eyes will colonize something
else so so that's so the brain has
proclivities towards a certain kind of
structure but especially early in
development it's unbelievably plastic
and so brains can be organized and
lateralized in a bunch of different ways
but so to simplify it what you do is you
kind of take okay well let's take the
most straightforward and typical brain
and talk about it as if it's the
canonical drink but I think what you can
say is regardless of where these systems
are localized they exist so it's an
oversimplification whatever doesn't
matter what you've got with regards to
your cortices is a quick and dirty
cortex and that's the right hemisphere
and then you've got a long-term detailed
cortex and that's the left hemisphere
left hemisphere is specialized for
language language cuts things up into
little tiny bitty pieces you know and
that's really useful if you're doing
little tiny bitty things and you should
be precision right pinpoint accuracy but
that takes a lot of time and a lot of
computation whereas the right hemisphere
says yeah yeah let's get to the bloody
point you know it so it captures the
thing in an image so like the monster I
showed you from the hippie cartoon
that's a right hemisphere thing it's an
image that represents a class of
entities and which of course images do
now there's this woman named can't
remember autistic woman she's developed
cattle handling facilities all across
what's her name Temple Grandin yes very
cool person I saw Temple Grandin speak
at the University of Arizona at the
consciousness conference and it was like
the funniest speech I'd ever seen in my
life not because it wasn't perfect it
was bloody perfect like she's a tough
woman she looks like a cowboy and she
spent a lot of time with animals she
kind of comes out on the stage in her
cowboy outfit and she's unbelievably
straightforward and without nuance she's
autistic she's severely autistic and she
you know her mother helped her a lot she
developed this thing that she would go
in
side to compress her and hold her was a
little machine and that would comfort
her in it anyways she turned herself
into quite the quite the person and she
thinks she thinks like an animal which
is why she can design cattle handling
facility often in slaughterhouses so
that the cattle don't get all freaked
out as they're on their way to their
eventual demise and so one of the things
she does is she walks through where the
cattle are going and anything that
bothers her she assumes will bother a
cow so for example if the cows are
walking through this state spiral
they're on their way to the
slaughterhouse and there's a coke cam
lying on the ground all the cows will
stop and look at the coke cat to normal
us now she talked a lot about how she
thought and what she said was she could
not devise abstract representations so
she said okay imagine imagine how a
child draws a house okay so what's what
does he know how child's house right
there's a triangle and a square on the
left and then there's another rectangle
and another kind of parallelogram and
then there's a door and two windows
right then there's a chimney with smoke
coming out which is quite cool it's like
why is that where's the smoke you know
you don't see that modern houses but
kids still do that
it's like then maybe there's a tree and
usually there's a son and then house
it's like you think always in that cute
a simple drawing it's like that drawing
is not simple you've never seen a house
that looks like that in your life it
looks nothing like a house it's not a
house it's not a picture it's a hero
glyph it's a pre-linguistic
representation and it's like the
essential elements of house and so you
might say what the child has done is
extracted out all those things that are
common across all houses and then
represented that it's not a drawing now
if you take artistic people sometimes
and you get them to draw you'll start in
one corner of the house and what they'll
draw is that house like with every damn
brick in place so there are autistic
people for example who they can look at
a building and they can count every
single window at one glass and then
there's another guy who in England who's
really famous this guy is just
completely out of
he's unbelievable they take him up in a
helicopter and show him the city that
he's never seen then he goes home and
has a piece of paper like as big as a
wall and he starts in one corner and he
draws the entire city you know and he
doesn't sketch it out right it's it's
from the bottom up and you know that's
autistic savant drawing and often what
happens is it's very realistic look you
know what happens if the autistic
drawing survived lers languages they
start being able to draw and that's
because the abstraction interferes with
the realism you know so it's really hard
to draw a hand and the reason for that
is if you draw a hand you draw a hero
glyph of a hand this is what Harun looks
like you try to draw your hand it's
really strange and one of the really
strange things about trying to draw your
hand is that in order to draw it you
have to stop seeing it as if it's a hand
and then it pops out you think my god
that's the weirdest-looking thing it's
like a tree root it's like you know it's
a claw because it's you know if you look
at your hand like that it looks nothing
like a hand that's how a hair looks what
the hell is that it's like some sort of
spider you know so but you have to see
it that way before you can draw it and
so well so partly what happens is that
your capacity for abstraction interferes
with your ability to see detail and
that's probably good it's one of the
ways that you simplify the world anyways
the right hemisphere looks like it's
specialized for anomaly now the way I
look at it is this okay so you've got
your hippocampus down there and it's
keeping track of the comparison between
what you want and what you think is
happening bang something emerges its
anomalous you don't know what the hell
is going on and so you freeze that's the
motoric representation then you start to
feel anxious then the right hemisphere
comes up with some pictures what might
this be you can experience this at home
for your own enjoyment let's say you're
home at 2:00 in the morning and it's
dark and you're alone okay maybe you've
watched a horror movies you're all
nicely pried you know and then you hear
a noise in another room and that noise
shouldn't be there and so you're going
to go investigate right and so let's say
the door is just a little bit open and
it's dark in the room and you have to
put your hand in to turn on the light
it's like you just watch what you're
imagining
populates that room with when you do
that it's like you know guy with ax
snake alligator like whatever but your
right hemisphere is going there maybe
one of this class of dangerous things in
there and what it's doing is basically
coming up with with a hypothesis
what sort of monster might be in there
and you're all sort of freaked out about
that even though you know that you know
who knows what happened you know nothing
something creepy but you're all like on
edge because your brain doesn't work at
night like it does in the day and
everyone knows that wake up in the
middle tonight it's like all manner of
Horrors go through your imagination and
that usually happens when you're asleep
you're asleep for that most of the time
but sometimes you wake up and it's like
you worry about everything so anyways so
that's the right hemisphere it's coming
up with pictures of what might be there
and they're generally monstrous pictures
and the reason for that is well it's
obvious what the reason for that is you
know now you'll probably turn the light
on and look anyways even though you
might sort of peer around the corner and
then when there's nothing you'll be
embarrassed about how foolish you are
but but you can see the instinctual
behavior right there and it's it's wise
you know there's a low probability that
something terrible is there but zero
times like low probability times
infinity equals large danger so if
there's a 2% chance that there's a
killer in there it pays to be you know a
little on the tense side because being
killed really sucks and so you're your
prime to feel negative emotion more
intensely right because you're so
vulnerable so anyways that's kind of
what the right hemisphere is up to it
does quick-and-dirty representation but
it also does categorization so it's not
it doesn't give you exactly realistic
representations of what's there what it
does instead is gives you categorical
representations and so you might say how
should you represent an unknown danger
you should use an amalgam of all known
dangers to represent it and that is what
it is in a sense you know like that's
why I talked to you earlier about the
category of all dangerous things so the
Aborigines in Australia have this this
category which is women fire
dangerous things it's like what you
think well why are all those things in
that category it's like well it's not
that hard to figure out if you think
about it but it's also a category that
you very frequently see say in Disney
cartoons
so the Wicked Queen for example in
Sleeping Beauty
I mean she's constantly bursting into
flames and turning into a dragon and no
one seems to object to that it makes
perfect sense that the Wicked Queen
would turn into a fire-breathing dragon
doesn't make any sense at all but
although it does but you know what it's
not a rational transformation but
because it's in keeping with an
archetypal structure everybody goes yeah
of course that's what she's going to do
it happens all the time in Disney movies
like Ursula remember her from from The
Little Mermaid she's trying to keep her
daughter from becoming conscious yeah
nice mother doing that and she traps old
Zeus you know he squeezes his soul to
death and traps him in the underworld
because he's also well we won't get into
that but anyways what happens to her
soul as when you finally get her
irritated now if she grows into this
huge ship destroying storm monster
that's part of the puss writer giant
octopus you think well that makes sense
okay it doesn't make a lot of sense but
it's a kind of hypothesis now that's a
representation of mother nature red in
tooth and claw and there's also a reason
that that's female it's not female it's
feminine it's actually a different thing
so but we'll get to that so the right
hemisphere well it's specialized for
anomaly it does quick and dirty analysis
under the influence of the limbic system
it's not linguistics so I would say it's
still dominated by the subcortical
systems and my suspicion is that animals
are still dominated by the subcortical
systems their brains work from the
bottom up we have a top-down module and
that's at least in part the left
hemisphere linguistic system and it's a
new thing that people have and it's
based on our capacity to abstract so
that would partly be visual like hero
glyphic and then also to transform
things into the linguistic form and it
seems to me that that's the part that we
really identify as ourself right because
it's weird if you're let's say you're
home alone and you get freaked out and
all these images come to mind
you know do you think of those images as
part of you you think more there are
things things that appeared to you and
that's what you think about your dreams
there are things that appear to you
they're not you it's like why would you
think that I mean they're in your
experience you'll space why is there
that separation between you and your
dream I had a dream not I thought up a
dream or look what I created it's like
there you are the observer it up comes a
dream it's very very weird and you know
it shows you that there are forces
operating in your psyche that are
impersonal genuinely impersonal and of
course that's part of what you call the
collective unconscious
so and it's the thing that generates
these weird images and protects you so
in its its nature that's for sure it can
be absolutely terrifying I mean people
can have dreams that are so terrible
that well like the one might my little
mean nephew had that's pretty damn nasty
little greasy dwarf things with big
beaks I mean that's an ugly that's a
very ugly representation and then if
that wasn't bad enough there had to be a
fire-breathing dragon behind them
creating them endlessly like it's no
bloody wonder he was waking up screaming
it's like oh no I figured out what life
is like it's like at 4:00 that's pretty
that's pretty traumatic so okay now the
left hemisphere this is this is al
Coleman Goldberg
I thought pauses to get one hemisphere
or system that operates when you know
what you're doing and when what you want
is happening and that's the happy talky
part that you know thinks it knows
what's the hell is going on
and then you have another part that only
turns on when you don't know what's
going on and it's full of anxiety and
negative emotion the right hemisphere by
the way is specialized for negative
emotion if you if you sustained right
prefrontal damage you become
inappropriately happy and you thankful
you're full of positive illusions you
think well that's an excellent thing
it's like it's not you make really
impulsive risky decisions and your life
goes directly to help because you need
the negative emotion obviously you know
the reason you suffer with negative
emotion is because if you didn't suffer
with negative emotion you you'd suffer
from being destroyed
those are your option
there are people by the way who are born
without pain and so is they Kay that's a
good deal it's like they never last past
20 and part of the reason for that is
you don't notice this but while you're
sitting there you're going like this all
the time and the reason for that is is
that if you sit for any length of time
on one part of your body then it doesn't
get much blood and it doesn't get
oxygenated and so if you do that it
a little bit little pain so you
shift your shift and you shift and so
you're just doing this all the time
because otherwise you wear your damn
body or you get bedsores or that sort of
thing well these people that don't have
any pain they just wear themselves out
so so you need the negative emotion you
know it keeps you going and and it can
get out of hand and have its own
pathologies but but it's definitely
necessary so the right hemisphere does
negative emotion inhibition of behavior
that's the freezing that's attendant on
anxiety does image processing holistic
thinking so it's the quick and dirty
hemisphere pattern recognition pattern
generation and gross motor actions and
that's interesting too right because the
gross motor action is again the quick
and dirty stuff you know if you need to
slap something away it doesn't really
matter that it's a you know a gross
motor gesture you don't have to go like
this and be precise it can just be fast
and and floppy and it'll still work
now the left hemisphere is specialized
for when you know what the hell's going
on and you can concentrate on the
details so and then you can think about
it in terms of the hierarchy that we
discussed right so what it implies is
that at the level of specific fine
detail motor output the left hemisphere
is operating and so that's kind of
associated with positive effect I know
exactly what I'm doing and I'm making
minor adjustments and everything's going
well and then if you go up the hierarchy
towards more and more abstracted
representations than increasingly that's
moving over into right hemisphere space
and so that's also partly why when you
disrupt those higher-order structures
that well literally all hell breaks
loose
so left hemisphere operation and
Explorer territory positive emotion
activation of behaviors so that's also
exploration word processing linear
thinking detail recognition
detail generation and fine motor action
so you need one system that works when
you don't know what's going on and you
need another system that works when you
do because sometimes you're where you
don't know what you're doing and
sometimes you're where you do know what
you're doing
now Ramachandran who's a fairly famous
neurologist who operates out of LA he
associated the totalitarian eagle with
hyper domination of the left hemisphere
and the reason he did that it's very
cool so he's got these patients that
have Bob what's it called
is it agnosia it isn't we'll call it
neglect neglect okay so this is what
happens okay you have a stroke and the
stroke affects the back part of the
right hemisphere all right so what
happens your left side is paralyzed you
can't do anything with it
okay so however you also don't notice
that it's not working and so one of the
things you might do if you do become
aware you're laying in bed you've had a
stroke and for some reason you notice
that there's an arm lying in there with
you and then what you do is you pick it
up with your other hand and you try to
throw it out of bed and when you find
out that it's attached to you because
it's not your arm you're not very happy
or maybe you throw yourself right out of
bed and then if someone gets you to draw
a clock you draw half a clock and if you
eat a plate full of food you eat half
the plate unless someone turns it and
then you eat half of that and so half
the world is gone it's hard to imagine
what that would be like a but I think
what it's sort of like is you know how
there's a whole world behind you and you
don't you don't detect it as not there
like it's not black or anything like
when your eyes are closed it's just not
there and I think what happens with
people with neglect is that the not
there becomes 3/4 instead of just half
it's something like that anyways so fine
so you don't know what's going on and
there you are like this and someone says
to you um I notice that you can't move
your left arm today and what do you say
you say well that's because I'm tired or
you say um I don't feel like moving it
and and so forth so you have this reason
that you're not going to move it and you
know
that you might say the same thing about
the left foot or whatever it's like yeah
well I don't feel like moving it and
you'll have some story about why you're
not going to move it okay so that's fine
so the Freudians thought about that is
traumatic denial you know that it was so
overwhelming to you that you lost the
left part of your body that you couldn't
face it and you just denied it happen
it's not a bad theory it's not quite
right but it's not a bad theory so so
fine so I'll tell you a couple of
associated stories let's say you're on
dialysis that sucks you have to have
this big thing in your arm that's like a
shunt and then you have to go get help
death to a dialysis machine like all the
time because your kidneys are failing
and so who wants that nobody so
everybody thinks time for a kidney
transplant so then they're on a long
waiting list they get one kidney that's
not very many kidneys and so then they
say okay you got your kidney and
everyone's thrilled about that here's
your anti-rejection medication make sure
you take it so then a year later you
lose your kidney why because you don't
take your cam anti-rejection medication
that's the most common reason you might
think well why in the world would you
not take your anti-rejection medication
while the Freudians would say denial
here's a different hypothesis your whole
map of you is person with kidney and
then you lose your kidneys and it's like
you're a whole weird thing that you have
no idea about and it's virtually
impossible for you to update your model
you think well does that make any sense
like have you ever lost a tooth right
what is your tongue do for like six
months you're sitting there and your
tongue is like fiddling away in there
like a mad dog investigating every
teensy nook and cranny like it's an
obsessive exploratory device and it
doesn't even when you don't want it to
and then six months later you get your
mouth remapped it's like that's just a
tooth man
lose a kidney and see what happens or
lose the whole left side of your body
it's like what are you gonna do about
that
well okay so then Ramachandran he's
testing these people for balance and so
what he does is he checks out this
phenomena called nystagmus and so if you
pour cold water in someone's ear their
eyes are moved back and
for it because it screws up the you know
you have a ballot system in your in your
ear and if you pour cold water in there
it screws it up and then your eyes move
back and forth and you know it's not
very pleasant so what he found was that
if he poured water in the cold water in
the left ear then all of a sudden the
people would wake up and go oh my god I
don't have the left side of my body and
then they would have a catastrophic
emotional experience they'd be all upset
about it and crying away which is of
course what they should do and then 20
minutes later it would wear off and and
then you'd say well you know is there
anything wrong with your left sorry did
they say well yeah I just don't feel
like moving it so what seems to have
happened is something like so there's a
body representation center let's say in
the back of the right hemisphere and you
blow that sucker out with a stroke and
that means you can't represent that part
of your body anymore but maybe there's
tatters of it left like it's like a
network that's damaged and under some
conditions you can more or less get it
to operate so you pour some cold water
in the year and you shock the whole
system and then there's enough
neurological activity so the network
kicks in even though it's damaged for
like ten minutes and then you get this
tremendous burst of negative emotion
which is what the right hemisphere
should be doing when you lose half your
body and you experience that and the old
left hemisphere is like flapping away
trying to account for this which it
can't because it's such a massive utter
catastrophe but then you know the the
shark wears off and bang the system
shuts back down and poof you're back in
denial so that's a good example of the
relationship between the left hemisphere
and the right hemisphere the left
hemisphere has a fixed idea about the
world so in some sense you might think
about it as the instantiation of your
latest avatar you can certainly see that
with people who are ideologically
possessed right they've got this verbal
system that accounts for the whole world
and there's just no damn way that
thing's going anywhere so you know and
it's got this totalitarian aspect
because it wants to explain every last
thing it doesn't like normally at all it
hasn't come to terms with anomaly at all
and there's no sense of transformation
within the system which is partly why to
tell
systems die it's like the Red Queen said
to Alice in Wonderland when she was in
the underworld in my kingdom you have to
run as fast as you can just to say in
the same place
that's why totalitarian systems don't
work because the damn environment keeps
shifting around on them you know and if
they're fixed in place the gap between
their theory and reality gets larger and
larger and larger and larger until
finally you know they fall into a pit
and that's the end of it so that's what
happens to people too if they don't stay
updated you know if they let things get
away on them eventually the ignored
reality comes flooding back and we'll
see that represented in mythology
because it's represented very nicely in
mythology that's why often dragons in
fairy tales for example and in the st.
George story sit and in The Hobbit for
that matter the dragon is an eternal
thing it lives underneath the earth and
most of the time it leaves you the hell
alone but now and then it comes back and
it tries to destroy the city and then
you have to zip out there and fight the
thing so you get it to go back in its
hole and maybe you get the treasure that
it's carrying and then it's back in the
hole for a while but that things coming
back it's always coming back so you
build the walls and all that that's fine
but a dragon can destroy any walls and
so walls aren't enough you have to be
prepared to go out there and fight the
damn thing and that's how you keep it at
bay and you know that basically means
that you have to maintain everything you
build it's something like that right
because otherwise it falls apart with
increasing entropy so all right so
Goldberg thought about this as an
anomaly system a novelty system and a
routinization system but I tended to
think about it more from an
anthropological or what would you call
it a F ethological perspective thinking
about an animal us in our natural
environment it's not so much novelty
versus routinization it's explored
versus unexplored territory and that's
what the world is made out of it's made
out of explored versus unexplored
territory and so there's a domain that
you inhabit which is the center of the
universe from a mythological perspective
with you right in the middle of it and
around you is this circle up which is
your place that you move around with you
and in that circle you know what the
hell's going on and that's partly
because you've mapped it but it's also
partly because you don't go outside of
it you know so you have your friends and
you have your routine and that's nested
inside your culture and you try to keep
that thing from flipping upside down and
you do that all sorts of ways partly by
doing the same thing all the time but
also partly by refusing to go anywhere
that might seriously challenge your
beliefs and you know fair enough you can
understand that although it makes you
weak to do that because you're not as
prepared as you might be so you could
say you know human beings are tribal
social animals that have a territory and
the territory then you think what's the
territory well let's say tree dwelling
chimp ancestors territories the jungle
it's like no it's not that's not the
territory the territory is a little bit
of the jungle plus the things that come
in from outside plus the primate
dominance hierarchy that exists in that
area right right so that's the that's
the territory that's the environment you
know because for mythological reasons we
tend to make a separation between the
environment and culture but it's yes
makes sense at one level of analysis but
at another level of analysis all it does
is screw you up because your territory
fundamentally isn't the world not the
natural objective world you want to stay
as far away from that thing as you
possibly can
your territory is that circle of people
with whom you spend 90% of your time and
so if you're a chimp for example or some
other kind of monkey highly social what
do you do all day you sleep you eat your
to leaves if you're a chimp and you
groom other chimps like it's constant
social interaction and you're jockeying
for position in the dominance hierarchy
like Mean Girls in that in that movie
you know and you're mapping out the
social territory knowing who's who and
what's what and then trying to get up
somewhere near the top and that's your
environment that's your environment and
so your your your world is that social
natural circle which is a four
dimensional territory because it's you
know it's got length width and height
plus it stretches across time
so it's this transforming natural entity
and then inside that there's a pyramid
and the pyramid is made out of all the
primates that you interact with and
that's the world a circle with a pyramid
on it now I'll give you a vision this is
a vision I had once when I was trying to
figure this stuff out okay so what is
the world so imagine that there's a
field in front of you that stretches as
far as you can see okay and then you're
flying above it and what you see
everywhere are these pyramids let's say
for the sake of argument that they're
like skyscrapers made out of glass
there's piers tears in them and you fly
down and ones here and ones here and
some of them overlap and some of them
are really big and some of them are
small and like but there's they're just
everywhere and you're flying around
above them and you fly close enough to
look inside what you see inside them are
people all packed together trying to
scramble up to the top and that's the
world that's the reality and the funny
thing is is that you could be in one of
those pyramids clambering away to the
top or you can be flying above it those
are your options and if you have to
choose you should be flying above it and
so the relationship between the self and
the ego avatar is the same as the
relationship between the thing that is
flying above and the thing that's within
one of those pyramids trying to scramble
to the top
you know you say well I'm going to get
to the top top of what well there's a
hundred talks there's 200 talks then you
might say is there anything above the
top well there is there's this part of
you that isn't entrapped within that
particular system and that can move from
place to place if you look at Egyptian
mythology so you know you see on the
back of the American dollar bill that's
a symbol of value right okay so what's
the pyramid there's a pyramid on it
right what's the top of the pyramid it's
a triangle separate from the pyramid
there's an eye inside it that's because
the top of the pyramid is an eye and
it's separate from the pyramid and what
that means fundamentally is that the
thing that transcends the structure is
attention voluntary attention now the
Egyptians worshiped voluntary attention
in the form of Horus because he was a he
was a god right Horus and I'll tell you
about Horus in detail but one of
Horace's avatars was the Falcon and the
reason for that is Falcons can really
really really really see and they fly
around and so they're like the Kings
eyes like like the little birds a zoo in
in Lion King right he was the King's
eyes the thing that flies around about
and he was a particular enemy of Skaar
remember Skaar eats about the beginning
and then spits about and the reason that
the Kings eyes is an enemy of scars
because the King's eyes can see what he
is right and he's the eternal force that
works to disrupt the kingdom and bring
everything into room classic myth
classic partly accounting for why that
was the largest selling highest-grossing
cartoon in Disney history right they got
the mythology pretty right so okay so
hmm
attention
then okay we'll do this so you might say
what's a human being like remember I
told you that when Penfield was mapping
the brain he was poking people and you
can either poke them along the sensory
strip which is if the motor strip is
here the sensory strip is just behind it
and the motor strip is where the motor
systems of your body are represented
insofar as you can control them and the
sensory strip is where the sensory
systems are represented insofar as you
can feel them so what this is is a that
the bodies laid out weirdly on the motor
cortex one of the things that's pretty
funny is that the genitalia area in the
sensory cortex is right beside the feet
and so I think you know there is that's
why people have foot fetishes and love
massages foot massages is because
they're spreading activation from the
foot area to the general area and god
only knows why that is maybe because you
had to have really sensitive feet to
trump around without you know stepping
on horrible things whatever so you can
you can put this weird stretched out
body representation together in a in a
representational form like this and they
call that the homunculus which is the
like the little man that exists inside
your brain so what you see that's the
motor homunculus not the sensory
homunculus but what so what do you see
well what's a person as far as its brain
is concerned
well hand that's for sure
thumb that's for sure it's like your
thumb is is represented as your whole
body and it's because motor your your
your chest your torso is hardly
represented at all why is that it's like
well how many things do you manipulate
with your chest like none right so you
don't you don't have motor control over
it so it's not represented so but the
hands man those things they're
represented like mad and so is the face
and the lips and the tongue and there's
a bunch of reasons for that one is that
when you're an infant you explore like
mad with your mouth but you do that
through your whole life because when you
eat you know what it's like if you're
eating something there's a bit of sand
in it like you you find it and you take
get out it's like you can detect this
teeny little thing that's not supposed
to be in your mouth well that's a good
thing because lots of things aren't
supposed to be in your mouth so that's
part of the reason then the other part
of the reason is well think about what
you do with your tongue I mean there's a
lot of things you do with your tongue
some of them are eating some of them are
talking some of them are all sorts of
intimate behaviors that thing is wired
up and it's wired up right at birth and
then it's the same with your lips and
your and the rest of your mouth you use
that to communicate so your hands won't
wander around taking the world apart and
putting it back together which is
exactly what your brain does and then
you blab about what you're doing to
everyone and that's basically a human
being and I like to think of this thing
as it's sort of the it's a comical
representation of the hero that goes out
to confront the world right because the
hero has two elements and one is explore
and that's sort of what that's where the
West is powerful I would say like we
have a really well developed mythology
of the exploratory hero but where we're
not so well developed is the second part
because in the second part of the
classic hero story you're supposed to
come back and communicate about what
you've found and so there's a individual
exploration element and then there's a
communicate and update the culture
element and both of those are equally
important and it's something that we
don't do well we don't have much respect
for tradition in the West and it's a
really really big problem because the
ethical responsibility of a human being
is to take the dead culture so that's
the dead father or the dead God and to
revivify it with attention and
communication and you fail to do that
then everything disappears and we we are
failing to do that we're leaving it all
behind instead it's not a good idea you
know if the old gods die as nietzsche
said they had new gods swoop in very
rapidly and if you think the old god was
bad you wait till the new gods get ahold
of you so while we saw what happened in
the 20th century right with all the
ideologies that sprang up in the
since of classical religious belief it's
like okay or you're not so thrilled with
Catholicism if you think about that is
you know the fundamental tradition of
the West you know with the witch
burnings and the Inquisition and all
about it's like yeah yeah well get a
load of the Nazis and then see what you
think so for the Communists for that
matter it's like from bad to worse in an
unimaginable way you know so and it's
partly because those archaic systems
those archaic religious systems they
weren't ideologies there are a whole
different class of thing and we don't
understand them very well and it's not
good because you cannot live without
understanding them you don't know who
you are and then you fall prey to weird
mental diseases like nihilism that's a
that's one another one is ideological
possession so you become a totalitarian
or a Nautilus and that's a bad outcome
and you might think well what's the
alternative well you know what happens
in Pinocchio right you watch Pinocchio
okay I often show up and help you to
this class but I don't know if I'm going
to do that this year
but anyways Pinocchio he's a puppet
marionette someone else is pulling his
strings has a wooden head he's not very
bright
he hasn't banged around the world at all
he's got a good farther there old
Geppetto who really would rather that he
was a real boy right a real person so
he's the kind of father that wants to
produce an individual and not a slave so
and that's why you know in his workshop
it's all friendly and there's a nice
fire he's making toys and there's lots
of music it's like go Geppetto he's a
good guy so he makes this little puppet
and he sends him out in the world says
go be a real boy well Pinocchio runs
into a whole class of different
obstacles one is evil right that's the
that's the coachman and the Italian
stereotype guy who makes him a dancing
puppet celebrity which i think is pretty
funny I mean that's really prescient you
know because you might think well what's
the goal of your typical boneheaded you
know mid adolescent in North America
it's like unarmed celebrity well that's
exactly what Pinocchio goes for first
and that doesn't work out so well
because he ends up a slave and then the
next thing that happens is he
capitalizes on the fact that he's
vulnerable
he's sick and goes off for a vacation
under the direction of the coachman
who's basically Satan in disguise then
he goes out to Treasure Island Pleasure
Island and meets all the delinquents who
were just like Nazis and it turns out
that in fact the whole ploy is to
enslave everyone to deprive them of
their voice that's the donkey's braying
and to make them into slaves
pretty damn horrifying and that was that
movie came out about the same time that
the Nazis were really you know grasping
power in Central Europe it's like they
got it exactly right here's what's
really going on behind the scenes so and
then what happens while Pinocchio turns
half way into a braying donkey because
you know he's gone off the path and in
order to get back on it he tries to go
home but it's too late he's grown up you
can't go home he's not a kid anymore
goes home and dad isn't there surprise
surprise because once you grow up and
you go home dad isn't there it's just
another human being so then what happens
well then he has to go into the ocean
well that's particularly weird right
it's like there he is half donkey he's a
puppet the Dove comes down and drops him
a message from God it's like the Holy
Spirit descending except it's actually
from the Blue Fairy weirdly enough and
the message says you have to go to the
deepest part of the ocean and rescue
your father it's like yeah that is what
you have to do if you don't want to be a
bloody puppet donkey you have to go down
into the depths and find your dead
father and you have to revivify him and
that's what happens so Pinocchio goes
way down there to the deepest depths it
finds monstro who's a monster so
terrible that the fish swim away just at
the sound of his voice just like what's
his name he who who you shall not be
named Voldemort
right you can't even say is damned name
same with monstro Pinocchio goes down
there goes into the whale what happens
Geppetto says there's no getting out of
this there's no getting out of this we
just have to sit here and cook fish and
Pinocchio things cook and then he starts
breaking up all the chairs and
everything and his father's freaking out
like what are you doing breaking all
these chairs what are we going to sit on
and then Pinocchio
fights them on fire he's a master of
fire it's a shamanic ritual but he is a
master of fire that's what human being
is he he gets everything burning of
course Geppetto is all freaked out about
that because what are they going to sit
on and Pinocchio thinks who cares about
sitting we're going to solve the problem
once and for all
and so then the whale turns into a
fire-breathing driving which is pretty
damn weird thing for a whale to do half
kills Pinocchio he washes up on shore
dead but he saves his father then at the
very end of the movie he's lying on his
bed all drown they're all like having a
show he's a dead puppet now it's like do
you want to be a live puppet or a dead
puppet well maybe the dead puppet is
better than the live puppet it depends
on where you're going so then he's on
the bed the Blue Fairy comes down and
says well you've been honest and
courageous dang now you're real you know
and then they have a little party and
that's that's just exactly right you got
it exactly right so that's how that's
part of the hero mythology is the
rescuing of the father once you have to
rescue the father because otherwise
you're a corpse like you're a historical
creature your cultural creature you're
you cannot live without your culture you
think you can but you can't it
disappears and and you don't even look
I'll give you an example in the
Mesopotamian creation myth which I'm
going to tell you about next week one of
the things that happens is that the
first round of gods so they're like
primordial forces they're pretty damn
careless and they killed their father
and they make this place to live on his
corpse okay that's where we live we live
on the corpse of our ancestors because
we live in this society it's dead it's
the product of dead people so it's got
this dead element but we're living on it
okay
they're very careless they kill it so
they render it completely dead well what
happens is taya Matt who's the mother of
chaos she comes flooding back and she
thinks oh you killed the thing that
protects you you just wait to see what
happens and that's exactly it
you killed the thing that structures you
you won't know it
it's like Nietzsche's prediction from
death of God it's like you killed this
you think ah it doesn't make any
difference it's like hah wrong it's it's
like the Striders protecting the hobbits
you get rid of that thing that protects
you and chaos comes flooding in and you
like you have no idea what's possible we
do though because we live through the
20th century we know exactly what's
possible you know hundreds of millions
of unnecessary deaths
that's what's possible we're lucky we
didn't blow the whole damn thing up so
and we still could so people pursuing
their dead ideologies you don't rescue
the dead father you're the puppet of
death that's what you are okay
I'm not cheery note